Crane's National Security Chief Alexi
denalov claimed progozian was in League
with not one but 14 senior Russian
Military Officers
pregosian is not an independent person
he is owned by high-ranking people in
President Putin's Inner Circle
one senior General widely reported to be
involved is Sergey sorovicin who hasn't
been seen since telling mutineers to
return to base was he one of the
generals that took part in this Mutiny
which there should be do you want me to
name them all
I can't
many analysts say President Putin has
been weakened by this revolt and Daniel
off believes he may face another
attempted Uprising
even if he executes the generals who had
some sort of part in the Mutiny this
will not affect the outcome the wheels
are in motion for Putin's demise